في السودان في اخبار متداوله بتتكلم عن
شغلانه اول مره بنسمع فيها متعهد بيع
كراسي متحركه اللي المتسولين
بالضبط هي هذه الوظيفه فعلا الاخبار بتقول
كانت انه في منطقه في العاصمه اسمها تقاطع
الشعب وفيها متسولين كثار في الشوارع وعلى
الاشارات وامام المحلات هناك في شخص بياجر
كراسي متحركه للمتسولين ب 20 يسهل عليهم
عملهم وانهم يحزنوا الناس على حالهم وبحسب
المتداول في الايجار للكرسي الواحد هو
1,000 جنيه سوداني في اليوم يعني دولار
ونصف او اكثر شويه في تفاعلكم احنا حبينا
نتاكد من الانباء وارسلنا كاميرا البرنامج
للمنطقه اللي الاخبار بتتكلم عنها وهذا ما
وجدنا
مثل ما شفت فعليا في متسولين كثار ومنهم
عدد لا باس فيه على كراسي متحركه بعضهم
واضح انه عنده اطراف مبتوره لكن في اخرين
ما يمكن يعني الجزم او التاكد من اصابتهم
من عدمها عموما الموضوع اثار استغراب
كثيرين وهو بصراحه يعني مستوى جديد من
استغلال الظروف الصعبه اللي اصلا سبب في
زياده نسبه التسول يعني في السودان ما في
ارقام رسميه لكن مصادر اكدت لنا انه في
الخرطوم بس في اكثر من 11000 متسول للاسف
[موسيقى]